let's talk a little bit about metallic
solids and here is an example of what a
metallic solid might look like they tend
to be shiny like this some would say
lustrous some of you might be guessing
maybe this is some type of
aluminum or silver it actually turns out
that this is sodium our same friend
sodium that we saw bonding with chlorine
to form sodium chloride and form ionic
solids it can actually bond with itself
with metallic bonds this right over here
you might guess is silver or something
it actually turns out this is calcium
and i don't know what you're thinking
isn't calcium kind of this chalky white
powder well no those are compounds
formed with calcium things like calcium
oxide but this right over here is pure
calcium and the reason why it has to be
in this container it is highly reactive
with oxygen so that's not oxygen that is
in this container it's some form of
inert gas but calcium when it just bonds
to itself with metallic bonds which
we'll talk about in a little bit it also
looks kind of similar it's this shiny
metallic or lustrous look to it
and what do you think this is
well this is something we're used to
associating with metals this is gold but
once again you can see it has this
lustrous property
so what is it about metals or metallic
solids that allow them to be lustrous in
this way and have other properties that
we're about to see
and to understand that we just have to
look at the periodic table of elements
and the most of the periodic table of
elements is actually some form of metal
you have in red right over here this
group 1 elements not including hydrogen
those are your alkali metals and you
have your alkaline earth metals your
transition metals your post transition
metals your metalloids it's really only
what you see in yellow and blue here
that are not your metals
so how do metals form solids when you
just have a pure sample of them well the
general idea you can look at your alkali
metals they all have that one valence
electron and to get to that stable outer
shell it's much easier for them to give
away a valence electron and that's why
we often see these folks participating
in ionic bonds they can be ionized quite
easily but if you have a pure sample of
them they can contribute electrons to a
c of electron one each
these alkaline earth metals they have
two valence electrons they too can be
ionized or if you have a pure sample
like in a calcium
they can contribute two valence
electrons to a sea of electrons and the
transition metals here have a similar
ability to contribute valence electrons
and so in general we can view metallic
solids as
having cations these positively charged
cations
in a sea of electrons so you have all
these electrons here i'll just try all
these minus charges that they're in
where does those electrons come from
well if you're looking at the alkali
metals each of those atoms could give
one electron to that c because it
doesn't really want that valence
electron if you're talking about
alkaline earth metals they can each
donate two electrons to that c
now given that you have this positive
charge in this c of electrons what do
you think of the properties how good do
you think this will be at conducting
electricity or heat and many of you
might guess if you looked at a wire
wires are made out of metals because
they are excellent at conducting
electricity or they tend to be excellent
at conducting electricity because you
have all of these electrons that can
move around and so if you
apply a voltage they will start moving
and conduct electricity and those
electrons can also be good at conducting
thermal energy or heat
now what would be we already talked
about them having this shiny lustrous
property but how easy would it be to
bend them with ionic solves we talked
about they can be strong but brittle as
soon as you try to shift them around a
little bit
they can break but what do you think is
going to happen here if let's say right
over here i would push really hard and
on the top i would have pushed really
hard to the left do you think this will
be brittle or do you think it will be
malleable it's easy to bend well if you
have a pure metallic solid it's actually
quite malleable if you just took
this top part and pushed it to the left
like this no big deal you have those
cations that are still in those that sea
of electrons and that's generally true
of metallic solids they are very
malleable they are not brittle in fact
so much so that oftentimes we want them
to be a little bit more rigid we want
them to be a little bit harder and
that's why we might do things like add
other elements into the metallic solid
for example pure iron is reasonably
malleable but if you want to make it
stronger you could stick carbon atoms in
between for example you could put a
carbon atom there or carbon atom over
there and that way it kind of disrupts
this electron c a little bit so it's not
quite as malleable and it'll be stronger
and more rigid so i'll leave you here
this is just an extension of what we've
already learned about metals and
metallic bonds to just realize why most
of the periodic table of elements that
we're familiar with has some of these
properties when they're when you have
pure solids of them